my talk at the table is filmmaker
alexandra pelosi
you may recall her from the national
attention she gained
with her documentary journeys with
george showing president george w bush
during his 2000 campaign pelosi who
happens to be the daughter
of house speaker nancy pelosi went back
on the road
last year to film a new movie it's
called american selfie
one nation shoots itself a lot of
meaning in that title
it shows americans documenting social
unrest during the pandemic
and as you're about to see one young
woman spoke about the growing demand
for racial justice i was 10 years old
when trayvon martin was murdered
and i remember watching the case
optimistic just knowing in my heart
zimmerman would be
recharged and then she was acquitted of
all charges and
eight years later absolutely nothing has
changed
we've had hashtag after hashtag after
hashtag and absolutely nothing is
changing
so that is why i'm out here saying black
lives matter yet again which is
something we shouldn't even have to be
saying
in big old 2020 that we have to be
saying our lives matter
it's it's absolutely insane
old 2020. that says it all alexandra
pelosi joins us now
uh alexandra good morning to you first
uh congratulations on this film
i love it i think sound from everyday
people is so powerful
and what i want to make clear for people
is it's called american selfie but
this is not found footage you were out
there doing the work talking to people
getting interviews like the one we just
heard
and about that interview that's a young
woman talking about
10 years of change you've been doing
this for 20 odd years you've seen a lot
of political change
what is the difference between america
of the george bush years and america
today
and what caused that change
well i should mention that that was the
day
that the united states military used
chemical agents to shoot
at rubber bullets and chemical weapons
at
peaceful protesters that young lady is
an example of who was there that day
when the government turned on peaceful
protesters
before the curfew in america i you know
i've been doing this a long time
i was a network news producer for a
decade i've been making documentaries
this is my 13th documentary
but i never thought in my lifetime that
i would see my own government
turn on its own people and to this day i
still haven't quite gotten over the fact
that i was there watching the national
guard
shoot tear gas at innocent protesters in
peace time
in america i mean you expect that from
third world countries it's very
venezuela
but this is not america and that's
something that i think
people need to think about hold the
mirror up to this country at this moment
in time and say
we're better than this america
there's a moment in the film i believe
you're in las vegas you're talking to a
young man and you ask him is america
broken
and he says yes do you agree is america
broken
and and who broke her i would blame
everything i put it on the lap of social
media i mean i think that regardless of
who you're going to vote for in this
election
the one thing every single person i talk
to all across america
for a year everyone the one thing
everyone could agree on is
social media is doing real damage to our
democracy
it's completely undermining the
conversation it's making us hate each
other
it's feeding everyone these toxic feeds
that are just
you know it's capitalizing on the divide
and i feel like
leading up to the election everyone
should just turn their phones off
because it's doing
so much damage to our mental health
yeah what what makes the film so
powerful is it toggles between
vastly different realities in this
country and you get incredible authentic
sound from people
who are more fact-based than others and
seeing the transition between the two
i mean it must have been neck breaking
for you as a reporter as a producer as a
filmmaker
what was it like shuttling between these
two worlds
well you know this is my 13th film i've
been doing this for a very long time
and i think that what what struck me
this time around
is how the the america's like a raw open
wound
you know you walk out there and you talk
to people people are really decent
americans are good nice people but the
way it looks on cable news is that we're
all just
it's toxic and i feel like when you go
out and you talk to people you don't get
that impression there are lots of
nice people you can meet everywhere
across america i think that
people just need to take a step back
what i'm trying to do is this is like an
artifact
i'm trying to hold up the mirror and say
to america like this is how we look in
2020. this is our selfie
and we all just need to sort of take
take a deep breath
and unplug from our social toxic social
media feeds
and try to remember that we you know
there is a possibility we can get all
we all can get along after this election
we can't there is hope
for us boy i hope so i hope we take a
long look in the mirror and decide we
don't like our outfit we make a change
uh alexandra pelosi thank you very much
it's a powerful powerful film the
documentary is called american selfie
one nation shoots itself
it debuts tonight at 9 pm eastern and
pacific
on showtime that is a division of viacom
cbs